hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
[Applause]
[Music]
Monday June 5th
2023 what's going on how are ya
how's it going with you oh Billy's in a
good mood
oh Billy's in a [__] good mood
um
you know I saw a movie I saw this Phil
Hartman restaurant
soul rest in peace Phil Hartman told us
there's a clip going around but he was
talking about how he did uh
like recorded one line
for Jack Nicholson's character in this
movie called The Border
um it's a I Don't Know Jack was probably
doing another movie they just needed one
line they couldn't get him and they had
to release the movie so Phil Harmon
could do the impression so he just
delivered the line there's a story he
told in the Dennis Miller show anyway
the great Andrew thermalist sent me that
clip and then and I was like
what's the Jack Nicholson movie called
The Border and I looked it up and it's
Jack Nicholson and Harvey Keitel did I
talk about this the last podcast I don't
remember all I know is I saw the movie
it's fantastic and by the way Harvey
Keitel [__] ripped in that movie and
he's like 40 years old
looks like a goddamn gymnast he's sort
of like the one of the first guys
that was like today in shape then
you know because back then all you had
to do was just sort of like you know
be in shape and wear but you could be
like in my shape and people that guy's
in good shape
he's hard-boiled I'll tell you but like
he was actually like [__] shred I'm
obviously professional athletes who are
in great shape but I mean just as far as
like actors
being in shape you know what I mean Burt
Reynolds was drinking the [__] Miller
High Life you know what I mean he had a
little pooch
you know he had he had the first couple
of ABS but he had he had a little
[__] little something or other there
Harvey can't tell [__]
was ripped in that movie and uh amazing
performance
Jack Nicholson I really I highly
recommend the movie although the ending
uh I don't know what happened it's put
it this way any movie that ends on a
freeze frame is usually not a good thing
we don't have money for reshoots we
don't know how to get out of this and
free stream go [__] yourself roll
credits but definitely a great movie and
if you're a fan of Dodge
I don't know what they call them the
Power Wagon what's what's the Dodge
version of the Chevy Blazer or the Ford
Bronco
um whatever that is the Dodge version of
that that's what the border patrol is
driving in that these two-door like
Ranger Green with the cream top why
don't they do two-tone anymore
um
where they use
you somebody sent me this joke a
comedian or some comedian was doing
or some I can't remember a humorist I
don't know what it was it was late
and
it was people from like my generation is
talking a lot of [__]
um
it's part of being old I think you just
talk a bunch of [__] I do it but Jesus
some of the [__] that they're saying
you know
nobody complained back in the 80s nobody
complained right and there's one of
these kids today they don't even know
how to do cursive they can't even
recursive it's like yeah
they don't need to
you know what I mean you can't download
[__] I can't upload [__] like we're the
idiots
we're literally looking at him like ah
what are you gonna do someday when you
gotta shoe a horse this generation can't
even churn butter
it's like uh little things things have
progressed
um
it's a very uh I don't know it's a very
common thing I'm trying I I I've been in
it pretty bad and I'm starting to
realize
you know it's my first time being old
you know so I don't know how to be old
and now I'm kind of realizing like
uh you kind of being a [__]
you know
I was going to say as my pubes turn the
color of autumn leaves but they were
already there
[Laughter]
I've been in the Autumn of my life since
I was 14.
um too much information bill
um Autumn of my years that's what it's
supposed to be
um
anyway I went on a great [__] flight
the other day I was gonna try to go all
the way up to Paso Robles so of course
like every day is like [__] perfect
to fly then the day I want to fly
there's like you know like a 2500 foot
ceiling
and you know when you go north out of La
like the the topography whatever you
call it it just uh it immediately you
know
it goes up like 2 000 feet quickly so I
mean the clouds were kind of meeting the
top of the San Gabriel so I was like you
know what I'll fly out to the coast I'll
go up by Santa Barbara I'll go by Santa
Ynez
you know I'll go buy uh Michael
Jackson's house and I'll [__] I'll go
up that way
so I was flying out there
it was kind of perfect weather for a
ginger
because it was cool out man and there
was cloud cover protecting my Ivory skin
my Alabaster Alabaster Alabaster torso
from the Sun
[__] that he is and uh it was cool
out and the visibility was all right
right so I end up flying out there
and it rained a little bit but I could
see on the coast that it was uh
the sun was out there so I was just like
all right it's just kind of raining
through here so I you know flew through
that [__] made the right turn went up to
Santa Barbara and I was just gonna fly
around
their air space but when I got all the
way up there
um
it it just it was getting bad it wasn't
getting big it was beyond my comfort
level and I was flying to like
a place where I'd never been before so
what did I do did I do the machismo
thing
you know I'm gonna keep going I'm gonna
get there and Bob will get there itis as
they call it I said [__] this I'll fly
it a different day
bang the yui came right back down and uh
transitioned through Oxnard Oxnard and
then uh
whatever that [__] military airport
is
point
Magoo or something like that
they go okay you can Trend I asked to
transition along the coast and they had
two airplanes military airplanes in the
pattern so they told me to transition
along
um
what is that the uh the Pacific Coast
Highway and I hadn't flown over there
for myself like I'm not really sure what
it is I imagine it's the one Highway
Inland the guy goes all right transition
three miles off the coast
and I'm like I'm a [__] helicopter I
don't know if he floats
or a life person I was like yeah [__]
so I just punched in direct to their
airport and I made sure I stayed I got
about to 2.8 miles and I'm just like
and I called him I'm like is this far
enough out they're like yeah you're good
I'm like fine then I just made a beeline
back in so I was only out there for like
a minute
and uh I was like well you know I'm on
the radio you know if I end up putting
in the drink they're gonna come and get
me I know they got some [__]
helicopters I'll tread water
um
and then I flew down the coast went
across Santa Monica and Hollywood and
all that type of [__] I just had like
this great flight so I realized because
I have kids as I talk about flying out
over the ocean I don't uh you know I
only have so much time to fly every
month so I'm just gonna do longer
flights
and I'm sick of the LA Basin area I've
done it a million times over the last
decade it's still fun but uh I want to
start going up to like wine country and
that type of [__]
you know
fly up there with my instructor bring my
wife up and stuff like that
um
I think could be a [__] cool ass
thing but anyways it was a big like
confidence build when anytime you fly
into some [__] you know you've done with
an instructor but this time you're doing
it by yourself like I was kind of proud
of myself I was like all right I didn't
freak out that it was raining a little
bit you know I can see the sun all right
this will clear up it's just raining
here
and lo and behold that's what happened I
was like look at me
look at me knowing things
um anyway
enough about me and my [__] dad hobby
accomplishments uh let's talk game one
of the Stanley Cup finals final final
Stanley Cup Final
all right uh against the relentless
the Unstoppable
they play 60 Minutes of hockey they
don't stop I swear to God their logo
should be the [__] Terminator
when that guy gave this piece he just
gonna keep coming
well that guy in platoon Charlie ain't
stopping for nothing man I got a bad
feeling about this one man they just
don't stop [__] playing
and it's an incredible lesson I would
think for any hockey coach to just do a
highlight reel of the amount of [__]
times in the [__] Vegas Knights did
it Vegas Nights go up two to one and
what do they do ah they kind of stopped
skating a little bit
they didn't play 20 minutes
they played like 19 minutes 25 seconds
and that's all those [__] goddamn
Panthers need they [__] scored a
short-handed goal
right little fluky thing the defenseman
breaks the stick
Vegas is on the [__] power play the
guy skates away man what the [__] is he
doing and I couldn't didn't realize it
until the uh the replay there
the guy broke the stick so he goes to
the bench another guy comes off the
bench or they gave him a stick one or
the other and in that time
where all of a sudden
it was uh it became four on four the
Panthers intercepted a pass and there's
a guy breaking out
as the defenseman is skating towards the
Zone he has to slam on the brakes they
go past him that other guy from the
[__] I don't know what team he was I
don't know anybody's name anymore
the old goal scorer 37 is streaking down
the ice following the play The Vegas guy
[__] doesn't skate
down the ice
the [__] guy goes wide for whatever
the goaltender goes way out of the net
the guy goes around the [__] net out
to the dude who kept skating it's in the
back of the net and then you see the
Vegas Knight like oh man what the [__]
what do you mean what the [__]
I've been watching this movie every
other night since April
when are these [__] [__] gonna wake
up and stop playing 54 minutes 53
minutes of hockey Jesus Christ the great
one Wayne Gretzky at the end of the
first period and the second period said
you gotta skate whistle to whistle
it's so obvious what the [__] they're
doing by the time Toronto decided to
start [__] playing they're already
down three games to none
I don't know what the [__] happened with
the hurricanes and the Bruins we could
have closed these [__] out but we
didn't we played 50 [__] four minutes
of hockey
and because of that we've been golfing
for the last [__] two months so
anyway
uh the Vegas Knights I don't know much
about them but they they looked pretty
impressive right so they get up four to
two
and I'm sitting on the couch with my
father-in-law and I just look over at
him there's about seven minutes left and
I go around three and a half minutes
left in this game there's gonna be a
stop at your play
and then the Panthers are gonna start
punching people in the head
cross-checking them and face washing
them and they're gonna try to get
matching miners roughings so they can
play four and four and try and steal
this [__] game right as a stand-up
comedian I knew it was coming I was off
by a minute four and a half minutes
four and a half minutes left right
left they start doing that that chicken
[__] style of [__] hockey and the
reason why I call it chicken [__] is
because you realize you can't skate five
on five
and you also realize that the NHL has
gotten rid of all the enforcers so now
you can go down there and start punching
goaltenders and goal scorers in the
[__] head
four or five times until they lose their
temper punch you back once and then get
matching [__] roughing penalties and
I swear to God the referees finally
because the the Vegas Knights just sat
there turning the other cheek it was
literally five on five of these guys
with gloves on just punching the Vegas
knights in the heads face washing them
and they're not doing anything
and I'm sitting there you know they they
finally break them up you know because
Chuck's in the middle of it great at
stirring things up and
they go to they go to the [__] box or
whatever and I'm just go over the
whatever the the [__] guy is between
the boxes and they're talking about the
penalties and they finally called it
they gave Vegas a four minute power play
in the game could chuck a gay misconduct
I have been waiting for that [__]
call
since the Bruins playing the [__]
goddamn St Louis Blues
um
and it started this era where you can be
way less talented than the other team
and you can just get away with all kinds
of [__] because the [__] League
penalized like back in the day you did
some [__] like that all of a sudden Bob
Probert
spun you around and knocked your head
into the [__] bleachers
all right John cortic rest his soul
Chris nylon Jay Miller these [__]
guys if you did any [__] like that any
of that [__]
chicken [__] hockey you've punched their
[__] goal scorer in the face that was
it Dave simenko rest assault that was
[__] it they came out and they beat
the [__] out of you they could get out
of the box and do it two more times
before they threw them out of the game
before you got a game misconduct and
that was the way the players police the
game and everybody sat there going like
why aren't they fighting they're police
in the [__] game so they've gotten
rid of the enforcers so now A Team like
the Carolina Panthers which I totally
respect but let's be honest that gutas
guy he's not a Norris Trophy winner they
don't have an Ovechkin on the team all
right that is a six with a bunch of
makeup on it and they're out there and
they're just they're playing 60 minutes
but they're also doing that [__] when
they get down and what ends up happening
is the [__] referees award him reward
them for that type of chicken [__]
[__] play where I mean of course
you're gonna punch the goaltender in the
head of course you're gonna [__] face
wash of course you're gonna do all of
that [__] there's nobody you have to
answer to anymore it's like there's a
substitute teacher out there so my thing
is I uh my Standing Ovation to that
officiating crew at the end of that game
for finally getting that [__] call
right
because my thing is if you're going to
get the enforces out of the game you
have to police that [__] with four
minute power plays and game misconducts
or what you're gonna have is mediocre
teams
um just beating the other team down
to their [__] Talent level it's just
I I [__] um
I've never respected that style of play
we can't beat you so now we're just
gonna [__] try to injure you or
whatever whatever you know
um I don't mind the instigating you know
uh back when there was in enforcers I
had no problem with that and a lot of
those instigators were actually
tough players because they knew that
they had a a Beatdown coming
and you know like you know from Sean
Avery back like those guys you know if
if you were instigating you also had to
fight you had you know you knew
something was coming but nowadays I feel
like you can just do it you get a free
pass it's sort of the NHL's answer to
that little safe space thing under the
hoop in um
in the NBA where it's just like even the
defensive player has to clear out of
there we just can't have people clogging
up and defending the basketball rim you
got to let these guys come in
and you might have unguarded layups and
dunks it's just [__] insane so anyway
plowing ahead here
they got it right
and if they continue to call the game
like that
um it's going to be interesting to see
how the Panthers react to it uh because
I really think that Vegas
keeping their composure in that moment
kind of crack the code
uh
uh of the Panthers with that horseshit
and the officiating
crew hats off to them actually sought
now who knows what's going to happen but
I will tell you they made twice they
made that mistake of not playing until
you know the end of the period and they
they gave up both goals that they gave
up that short-handed goal
and uh and that other one and even
though it was a set play off the
Face-Off
that second goal that they got it's like
where was the Face-Off it was in your
[__] Zone because you guys
were content to go into the [__]
locker room with a 2-1 victory
I mean two one uh two one lead like okay
two one that's pretty good A little poke
check here what the [__] happened backer
than that two to two
um so we'll see what we'll see what
happens I uh this is a hard one because
I kind of
as far as who I'm rooting for
um Bruce Cassidy former Bruins coach and
I'm loving that
um
and then also the way the Panthers have
just you know how do you not root for a
[__] eighth seed that's gone all the
way to the finals final the Stanley Cup
Final
and with that over to the NBA finals
which game two is happening here in a
couple of hours
um I'm recording in the afternoon
because I got I got a set tonight
um
was I gonna say uh
I only watched about
I think I saw like the last
quarter
of the game and Denver was just handling
Miami and they were up at like 21 points
and uh but then the Miami Heat man they
ain't [__] quitting
it's kind of amazing that they have two
that both my city of Miami has two eight
seats that are in the final and the
finals
right
um
so they ended up cutting the lead and
went all the way down to nine you know
the announcers games and it's like all
of a sudden it's down to 12. it's down
to 10 down to nine so uh
what I took away from that game other
than the fact
that you know I didn't know I don't know
[__]
about hoop especially out in the West
uh but that yokich guy
um
I watched some highlight reels of that
dude
and it's amazing he does that Larry Bird
pass the two-handed over you know no
look over the top of your head
and then he does all these Magic Johnson
passes he kind of can do both players
passes but he looks like Larry Bird the
whole time
so that's going to be fun to watch but
um
what I loved about the end of the game
is the game ends Miami loses and you see
Jimmy Butler walking off the court
talking to another player strategizing
so
um
I feel like both the Stanley Cup and the
NBA
their last round here is two similar
Tales where you have a more talented
team fighting a team
that is like a goddamn Wolverine or a
badger and then just you ever see like
those animal videos were like a bunch of
wolves were like
surround a badger or a Wolverine and the
thing like fights off the whole [__]
pack I feel like that's the mentality of
both Miami teams
um and I'm also excited you know that
it's not the [__] Warriors or the
Lakers and a bunch of [__] free
agents again that kind of seem like
there's
you know they're not super teams or
whatever but that's you know it's it's a
different time though it's a different
time I'm trying to be the the
understanding
[__] old ass [__] that I am
um
so anyway uh
Friday was
my wife's birthday and then Saturday was
my son's birthday and uh
I just had the best time I've been home
for like
48 hours straight haven't even left had
a bunch of kids over
for my son's birthday swimming in the
pool
um
you know grilling I made some cupcakes
had a little bit of help from a friend
you know
um
and uh actually a lot of help from a
friend and uh
and then for my wife's birthday we went
out to dinner
and um
I bought her this beautiful dress
I did a thing I actually found out her
sizes and went out and bought her a
beautiful dress and she absolutely loved
it and looked
stunning in it
and uh
so then I went out to eat with her and
all her family and I made the mistake
because I had such a good day I crushed
it
so hard on the birthday that I was like
you know what I'm gonna take an edible
you know
I am
[__]
I know I usually take the first 10 days
off of every month but you know
it's my birthday month I'll do june 11th
to June 21st this month [__] it right so
I take it and I kind of had forgotten
that I hadn't eaten much that day
because we were going to this amazing
restaurant one of Nia's favorite
restaurants
and I was like all right and she's like
the food's unbelievable and I was like
I'm gonna [__] throw down there so I
took the edible and woof
that thing hit me quickly
and uh I was social and then I wasn't
for like an hour and then I like to
think I came back and saved it but I was
flying
Skyrocket in flight
I like the Edibles though I like them
way better than smoking it just seems a
lot more healthy or you know something I
think just smoking it's just really
obvious what you're doing to yourself
we're like that [__] you know the
Edibles it's so funny they have like
sugar on them and stuff
it's so like one it's so funny they
legalize weed and they're gonna somehow
make it
you know
even more unhealthy that's what I'm kind
of worried about like mushrooms
as they're finding out you know or they
probably already knew how healing those
things could be if done correctly
eventually they'll become like the
McDonald's version they'll have that
pink slime in them
you know and then who's that Monsanto
Monsanto they changed their name took
over the food supply and what our food
supply has become they'll do that to the
you know just heartless
heartless people so
um speaking of that I'm enjoying
watching Joe Biden get blamed for the
fact that the country's bankrupt it's
like the country I don't know if you
guys have realized this this country has
been bankrupt sits way back
uh towards the end of George W bush
uh
uh they started that [__] War over
there or brought us in there and they
had no [__] exit strategy and it cost
us like a what a trillion dollars a day
um
yeah we have been just printing money
with nothing behind it every August
for like the last over a decade and uh
but unfortunately people are you know
they look at politics like sports they
just keep doing the [__] Democrats
the libtards oh these conservative
right-wing religious freaks
sit there [__] arguing about small
stuff I always compare it to like like
how the average person is when they talk
about politics what they're what they
their priority is it's like literally
like a tornado just knocked down your
house and you're screaming about how you
need a new toaster it's like no we need
a new house
why don't we get that first
before you start dealing with appliances
we don't have any Outlets to plug them
into
all right
I told myself I wasn't going to get you
know
I wasn't going to lose my [__] here all
right I watched that F1 race today the
one from Spain
and uh yeah you know I like F1 or
whatever but it's just always the same
thing now instead of watching Lewis
Hamilton get out in front in the first
turn now it's the uh the other guy there
um what's his name the Red Bull guy
Sebastian Vettel is that who the [__] it
is yeah he just gets out front and then
that's it I think that's who won the
race
um that's what I'm telling you guys you
got to watch MotoGP
all right first of all it's only like 22
23 laps every [__] lap matters
there's no pit stops and they're just
[__] flying passing each other
you know and when they crash like
literally a guy goes flying off of a
motorcycle
it's like watching Raiders of the Lost
Ark when those people were trying to
climb onto his truck
um
anyway okay speaking of that can can you
watch is that TT race in the Isle of Man
coming up and can you watch that live
you probably can't because somebody dies
every year
um all right I'm done running my Yap
here let's do the uh let's do the
um the reads for the week policy genius
everybody you know a good life insurance
plan can give you peace of mind that if
something happens to you
uh put it down uh your family will have
a safety net to cover uh mortgage
payments do you want me to hold the
ladder that would have been a better one
uh no I'm good college costs are other
expenses are you sure you're okay to
drive so they can get back on their feet
and focus on what's most important dude
please tell me you wore a condom these
are all things that people get said to
before their family members uh cash in
their life insurance policy uh with
policy genius you can find life
insurance
policies that start at just 25 dollars
per month for a million dollars of color
coverage
some options offer coverage in as little
as a week and have avoid unnecessary
medical exam
uh
policy genius has licensed agents who
can help you find the best fit for your
needs they work for you not the
insurance company that means they don't
have an incentive to recommend one
insurer over another so you can trust
their guidance policy Geniuses for
parents caregivers or anyone who has
people who depend on them this is really
important people I'm in a part of my
life where a lot of people I know have
died and they had loved ones and they
did not have this stuff taken care of as
a man you got to do it deal with your
mortality and make sure everybody's okay
the only thing they should have to deal
with when you die is their grief that's
it uh they simp they simplify the
process of getting life insurance you
can protect the people you love there
are no added fees and your personal
details are private no wonder they have
thousands of five star reviews on Google
and trustpilot your loved ones deserve a
financial safety net you deserve a
smarter way to find and buy it head to
policy genius or click the link in the
description to get your free insurance
quotes and see how much you could say
save that's policygenius.com
oh look who it is everybody the classics
the classic lineup
stamps.com
they're back with their original drama
uh with so much of our world digitized
or automated why stick to Old School
mailing and shipping if you mail or ship
often let stamps.com do the hard part
for you simply pre print postage
and shipping labels right from your home
or office do you know my daughter is
reading me books now
and when she she reads like the Cat in
the Hat she goes the Cat in the Hat came
into the house
and on the floor it saw a mouse she kept
doing that I was going why are you doing
that she's like because there's
exclamation points
she thinks it means just yell the last
word it's the [__]
you know I'm not going to correct her
for another couple of weeks because it's
just too [__] cute to watch anyway
stamps.com with so much of our world
digitized or automated why stick to Old
School mailing and shipping if you mail
or shipped often let stamps.com do the
hard part for you simply print Postage
and shipping labels right from your home
or office it's ready to go in minutes no
long lines or complicated setup required
a post office in your office postage
rates just increased again luckily
stamps.com has the best discounts in the
industry they have amazing Partnerships
with the USPS and the ups and ups for
unbeatable rates up to 84 percent off
plus stamps.com automatically tells you
your cheapest and fastest shipping
options get access to the United States
Postal Service or United Parcel Services
you need right from your computer
anytime day or night no lines no traffic
no waiting and if you sell products
online stampscott.com seamlessly
connects you with every major
Marketplace and shopping cart avoid the
hassle man and get started today with
stamps.com sign up with the promo code
Burr for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the page and enter the code
Burr b-u-r-r here's another thing that I
love about the Florida Panthers
um is when they're on the power play if
you look at you know they go into the
box the four-man box there if you look
at it they're pressuring the puck still
and if you watch the Vegas Knights and
all these other guys that play they just
sort of like don't leave your your
little circle area just kind of you know
stay in the Box stay in the Box they
[__] pressure the goddamn puck now
granted they got [__] on it I can't
remember if they were on the power play
or not somehow they had three guys
behind the net so I thought they were on
the uh uh on the wrong side of a power
play
but uh
generally speaking they just constantly
coming at you man I don't understand why
more teams don't play that way
um if they can have that level of
imagine if you played that way and you
actually had like superstars on your
team
um I know what it was gonna mess up my
mullet
um all right that's the first round
draft pick uh Bill great emails
all right well let's see oh here's a
question I had what happens when you say
okay Boomer to Boomer Esiason does he
get what you're saying
is he like okay what
no no I meant like your generation and
he goes oh
okay
um
sorry the [__] did it go all right here
we go Moto Racing
uh hey there Billy blue balls
um I am not Billy blue balls all right
I'm Billy satisfied if you know what I
mean oh Jesus
I'm just writing to let you know that
for the next two weeks oh here it is the
Isle of Man TT races are on there's an
app that you can watch every session
live online at
uh that https colon slash slash TT plus
Dash checkout dot i o m
t t races.com
I should just post that and having spent
uh is that 20 pounds is it 20 quid is
quid and pounds the same thing is that
like dollars and bucks
on it last year I can honestly say it's
the best money I've ever spent and I'm
Scottish
so me and my money aren't easily parted
all the best
you know what I'm going to look that up
why why this why are the Scottish people
considered cheap
um
why are
Scottish
remember my dad used to say that my
mother had some Scottish blood when you
know he wanted to buy some and she
wouldn't ah Christ I tell you it's that
[__] Scottish blood
uh why are Scottish people
considered
cheap
that's because the English took her
everything they had
cheap Scots and disappearing stereotypes
I'm not looking for the [__] woke
[__] I want the why did Scottish people
acquire a reputation for frugality
uh
first thing it says if you were abused
by a priest as a child you have rights
priests abuse victims in California
still have rights and can file a lawsuit
anonymously we believe you
slash you want to make money off of the
most horrible thing that could ever
happen to you uh the Scottish reputation
for frugality
may have roots in this historical events
such as the Highland clearances a period
of mass eviction of tenants from their
lands in the 18th
in 19th century was that done by the
English this forced many Scots to become
resourceful and Frugal in order to
survive additionally Presbyterian work
ethic which emphasized hard work and
thriftness
thriftiness may have contributed to the
Scottish reputation for frugality
finally the harsh climate and rugged
terrain of Scott Scotland may also
encourage
also have encouraged a culture of
resourcefulness and carefulness careful
use of resources
the Highland
clearances what are the odds the English
are behind this
that's always a good guess
kind of anywhere in the Highland
clearances
let's see here come on Wikipedia
you can do it
all right the Highland clearances were
uh
uh the eviction of the gaels
were the forced evictions of a
significant number of tenants in
Scottish Highland Highlands and Islands
mostly in two phases 1750 and 1860.
well from 1750 to 1860 the first phase
revolted from agricultural Improvement
driven by the need for landlords to
increase their income oh it's the
slumlords my apologies to the English
many had substantial debts with actual
or potential bankruptcy being a large
part of the story of the clearances this
involved the enclosure of the Open
Fields managed on the Run rig system and
shared grazing
these are usually replaced with
large-scales pastoral Farms on which
much higher rents were paid this is kind
of what ended up happening in America
where they're all corporate Farms now
pastoral farming region regions as
ranching
livestock farming or grazing is aimed
all right
just seems like the usual like
you know what's amazing I would think
like you know
I don't understand why these people go
on these shooting sprees and they just
shoot regular hard-working people it's
like if you want to go out in a blaze of
glory I mean why don't you go shoot some
of these [__]
[__] that come up with this [__]
or don't why am I advocating in mass
shooting I am not okay I'm just [__]
Thinking Out Loud here whatever people I
don't edit the podcast all right I don't
edit myself I just you know I just have
a thought and I say Jesus Christ this is
a comedy podcast don't take it seriously
no one here at the Monday Morning
podcast Advocates doing something like
that
even though you're already out of your
[__] mind if you went to go and do it
they would still somehow try to blame a
comedian you know or an actor or
somebody like that why yeah blame them
don't blame people that get us in
endless [__] Wars with no [__]
solution that bankrupts it don't blame
those guys blame a tie
what color is your tie I don't like you
what color is your tie oh you can do no
wrong
um that works both both ways by the way
you know I love all these liberals that
are up in arms about uh
[__] Trump and how he treats women
but they could care less about a certain
[__] pasty thigh uh McDonald's eating
[__] that went to a certain Island
allegedly a good [__] 25 30 times all
right game changing NBA players
all right so last time I I was wondering
and you know
introduce this debate here what I feel
you know if you're going to get compared
to a Gretzky a Jordan A Lawrence Taylor
I feel like you have to do
you have to change the game you have to
do the impossible what you do on the
field people didn't think was possible
and then you do it you show it is
possible and then your game then becomes
the standard and then all of a sudden it
takes about two or three generations
then your play becomes standard
and that's the hard thing with younger
people when they look at like Jordan
highlights and [__] like that they don't
understand that no one had done [__]
like that like he came up with it it's
kind of like the Beatles people being
like they're not that groundbreaking you
know [__] 60 years later it's like
well that's because everyone has taken
from them
you know what I mean so anyway so my
opinion is like uh yeah if you change
the game
you change the game and then people you
actually ruin the game for a minute
because people can't do what you're
doing but they want to do it too like uh
when Jordan dominated the game all of a
sudden there was you know and didn't
need a big man to feed
down low uh all of a sudden everybody
started playing like that and they
weren't as good as him and it became
awful [__] basketball for a while and
right now I I think the Steph Curry
influence
where there's kids now pulling up from
like [__] half court instead of
trying to work the ball around the
perimeter I can't imagine Bobby Knight
trying to [__] coach now Jesus Christ
you think he slapped people then
um anyway so that that was that's that's
just my opinion on on what makes
somebody
the greatest so game changing NBA
players
knee heyo Billy boy greetings from China
okay I can learn how to say that I
disrespect you're gonna write all the
way in from China you could at least
learn how to say hello
you know I just talked for another
[__] 20 minutes I didn't realize when
I watched that
woman from China's video
on how to say hello in Chinese that
because it was audio it shut off my
recorder on my phone
uh nihau Billy boy greetings from China
heard your opinions on the game-changing
players and I only agree with you
partially okay so this was uh yeah yeah
I already explained this uh yes Michael
this person goes to say Michael Jordan
and Curry were the most influential
players in 30 years and young guys in
their era all try to imitate their game
I think people are still doing that with
Steph Curry where I feel like Michael
Jordan's moves
and the stuff the way he played the game
has been absorbed into the league the
same way when you have a groundbreaking
band
that comes along and changes music then
everybody just
is influence rips them off and then when
enough time goes by young people go back
and look at The Originators and they go
what's the big deal everybody plays
guitar like that or everybody can write
a song like that what's the big deal
um so that's why it's hard as an older
person to uh
uh you know
talk to younger people about what
certain players did because you were
there
when it happened and I I always equate
that to like um
remember my math teacher going like you
guys have no idea what it was like
when a Beatles album came out like what
the [__] that experience was like and
that was in the 80s and they had already
The Beatles had already been ripped off
for like 20 years so anyway here we go
let's hear what this person has to say
however for the most for most people uh
imitating their game only means
imitating their signature moves everyone
can do a post-up fade away like Michael
Jordan or Kobe uh Kobe is not in Michael
Jordan's class okay Kobe could do
Michael Jordan's moves but I never saw
Kobe do anything
like uh you know
it's just the the gap between Michael
Jordan
and Dr J
was like infinite
which you never thought was gonna be
like he was so [__] far ahead of
everybody Kobe came along and could play
like Michael
could play as good as Michael I'll give
him that but he didn't play better he
didn't change the game I hate that he's
passed away for obvious reasons but like
I always whenever I criticize this game
I feel like I'm being disrespectful I'm
just I'm not disrespecting
the man okay he was fine I know I always
say I never saw a [__] guy with two
people hanging all over him [__] you
know
behind the arc and still hit the
three-pointer so consistently he was a
[__] beast 100 uh but I don't he
didn't change the game the way Michael
did he just didn't all right and every
everyone can dribble twice and shoot a
three like Curry
everyone can do that
well
all right well if everyone can do that
they're doing it because they saw him
everyone could be 10 feet behind the
[__] three-point Arc and consistently
hit it at an NBA level
uh
I have to be honest with you what Steph
Curry is doing is has never been done
and he does it on a consistent level
that he's showing that human beings have
this capability so what will happen you
watch with his game young fellas his
game is going to get absorbed into the
into the NBA
and in 20 years people are going to
watch what Steph Curry did and be like
what's the big deal I can [__] do
that I can do that it's like you can do
that because he showed everybody that it
was possible
anyway this person goes only very few
people can make a layup while two guys
are trying to drag him or her down
that's not true they've always had
people like that
there's always been the [__] Charles
Barkley Larry Johnson
just [__]
I'm trying to think Moses Malone there's
always been those guys that can Bang
um
although those guys have kind of been
phased out of the game I feel
uh the guy goes that's why we hardly see
people try to play like super powerful
guys such as LeBron and Shaq yes I feel
like LeBron and Shaq are physical
anomalies but they didn't change the
game
um this guy goes on to say that doesn't
mean these guys couldn't change the game
in fact the NBA changed rules several
times because of these super beings they
changed the goaltending rule because of
Wilt Chamberlain
yes I wouldn't put Shaq and LeBron and
will Chamberlain's category they made
like
a bunch of rules
to stop Will Chamberlain uh they made
dunking illegal
um
they did everything to try because that
guy was like 20 years ahead of his time
you got to be 20 years ahead of your
time I feel
um the five second back to the basket
violation is known as the Charles
Barkley rule zone defense was brought
back to tackle shot into tackle Shack
yeah those are just they mean okay
there's the Sean Avery rule I mean I'm
talking about like changing the game not
like somebody's doing some [__] like all
right we gotta do this to there's always
rules like that
like you know if you come out you put
Vaseline in the bilia Cappy you know and
then they go you can't [__] do that
are you now in the same categories Babe
Ruth
I don't know what you're saying there
um I do highly agree with you on LeBron
though he did not change how people play
he was dominating he's still dominating
uh but not to the point that the league
has to change rules he didn't change the
sport
how you play but he did change the
league after they take my talents to
South Beach too many super teams were
made by trading instead of good
old-fashioned drafting
that was definitely a watershed moment
but uh I think the Kobe Shack Phil
Jackson
I mean there's three free agents right
there Charlotte Hornet of Orlando Magic
and then
um
you know the coach of the Bulls
which is another thing they go you know
Michael Jordan had Phil Jackson was like
Michael Phil Jackson was former Nick
Phil Jackson assistant coach Phil
Jackson
he became the legend of Phil Jackson
happened in Chicago it's not like they
got him and we're like all right this
guy's a proven coach that wins a
championship anyway P.S I have a few I
have a Chinese joke about America for
you oh I love this [__] let's hear it
what's smack are you talking about us a
few days ago China manned space
exploration office announced that they
plan to go to the Moon by 2030 and it
soon became a Hot Topic on the internet
some people in China don't believe the
1969 Neil Armstrong moon landing is true
so people are discussing how we can find
out the truth when we get up there oh my
God that's amazing
put the debate to bed some say we can
bring back lunar soil and compare ours
to what NASA gave us decades ago Dude I
can tell you right now
if we fake that lunar Landing there is
no [__] way you're getting a Ziploc
bag
of our Mojave Desert [__] sand we're
not sending it to you anyway some
suggest that we can we can go find that
flag Neil Armstrong left on the moon to
prove whether or not we got there
all right here's the joke well there's a
very quick and simple way to tell if the
moon landing by America is true when you
land on the moon and you find no natives
on the moon
then you know the Americans were there
before
[Laughter]
that's a [__] great joke
they're talking about the genocide of
the Native Americans there you go great
[__] joke that's what I love about
travel
you know when you meet people from other
countries another other part of the
world and you realize that they break
balls the same way you do that's
fantastic and then these pieces of [__]
with the different colored ties try to
tell you that everybody in that country
is evil they're not like whoever wrote
that joke [__] fantastic joke
and uh you know that's the kind of
person you want to go have a beer with
you know but you watch CNN and FOX NOW
evil doers and all this [__] oh shut up
Bill and I'm it's true though anyway the
person says that's it love your
stand-ups love your podcast keep up the
good work come visit China sometime and
go [__] yourself
I had an eyelash on my phone there yeah
I'd love to come back there I went to
Hong Kong one time I still
think about the food that I had there
still
still the greatest
from Singapore
to to China the [__]
dumplings that I had there
I they would I couldn't believe they
didn't float up to the [__] ceiling
they were so light oh my God they were
[__] amazing
um anyway keeping your son in his room
oh boy I'm gonna get some parental
advice here God knows that always
happens you open your [__] Yap here
we go hi Bill if you put a child safety
doorknob cover on the inside of your
son's room he cannot open his door and
get into your room I did that with three
kids my wife thought it was kind of
[__] up to do that's my initial
feeling that it's kind of [__] up
this guy goes on to say I told her that
if we had a house fire we'd know the
kids were in their room and we wouldn't
have to search for them but what if the
fires in their room and they can't get
out
the guy says parentheses I built a
career out of pitching worst case
scenarios to get my way
um
the guy goes on to say I can't guarantee
that he won't Hoot and Holler about
wanting to get out eventually he'll
figure out how to
how to defeat you but maybe you'll get
some uninterrupted sleep for a stretch
of time I hated getting up in the middle
of the night and I bet you do too I
really enjoy all your stuff all the best
to you and yours from the Boston area
um no you know
I don't know I look I love to sleep
through the night he's he's
barely doing it now but I I just kind of
like um
I just welcome back
come on buddy what are we doing so and
then when he comes in early in the
morning like 5 30 or 6
I opened my eyes and the sun's out at
that point I just walk him back into his
room and then there's a adult bed in
there and I just you know
sleep in that so he he got in the bed
this morning and like uh he listens to
that cocoa melon stuff
and they got this song that they sing
they go uh you know do you like broccoli
yes I do yes I do do you like pizza yes
I do yes I do then it goes do you like
broccoli Pizza
no I don't yucky and the kids like
saying no I don't and saying yucky and
[__] and they also like uh you know
they're teaching them that certain
things don't go together or whatever
right so I was joking around with him
and I was singing his name you know
do you like that yes I do yes I do and
then I would combine it with something
else do you like so and so you know
popcorn no I don't yucky right
so 5 30 in the morning I'm in there I
put her to bed I get the big bed and
then he comes walking over
he gets in the bed with me I'm like I
just don't have the energy to get back
up again
and he's like rubbing my head slapping
it [__] squeezing my ear kicking me
doing all of this [__] and then he just
starts singing he goes do you like dada
yes I do yes I do and then he skipped
the next verse and he just goes do you
like Dada granola
no I don't yucky
and I just start cracking up so I would
miss out on those moments as tired as I
am I'd miss out on those moments and I
don't want to do that and uh
I don't mind being tired as a parent
it's part of being a parent and uh
my son is the greatest smile
and he's such a happy happy kid which
I'm really proud of
I really feel like
you know
I guess a benchmark of your
parental skills at least when they're
young before they get into the teenage
angst and then you really can't
you just try to navigate them through
that but I mean you really can't control
their moods but like under 10 I feel
like if they're happy
and that type of stuff uh you're doing a
great job like we went out this morning
because it's sort of like their birthday
weekend and I went out and I got some
you know pastries or whatever and I
brought both my kids I take my kids
everywhere
um
I just really believe in that you know
bringing them along
you know and then you can really subtly
like expose them to music and that type
of stuff like I've been on this [__]
1960s Miles Davis kick and at first they
were like what is this now they're just
sort of listening to it and what I love
is they're so young and
um
just absorbing things like
a sponge I really think Tony Williams
drumming and
Miles Davis and and
you know John Coltrane and all that to
have that
in them
along with my AC DC and my uh all of my
wife's amazing music is just like a
great thing
to uh
expose them to and you know what else
was cool was we have like these dance
parties like once a week I started doing
this right because I didn't want like uh
my daughter and my son to have like
anxiety
like I did about any type of social
situations because I I just you know did
not experience a lot of them then all of
a sudden by the time I got to him I was
like you know
just hopelessly behind and it caused me
to get even more introverted and then
and it's just you know not a fun place
to be right so
last week we were doing like the
Electric Slide teach them how to do the
Electric Slide then there's the the
Cha-Cha Slide where's the electric slide
with the Cha-cha-cha step or whatever
and they you know when kids were having
a blast and all that and it just so
happens my wife ends up going to a party
with one of her friends
brings my daughter and they do the
Cha-cha-cha slide and my daughter got up
and did it and I I was so [__] happy
I was like yeah that's what you do
something you struggled with you make
sure your kids you know you try to fix
that I know that they're going to have
their problems or whatever but I think
that's a that's a
that's a big thing so in answer to your
question I'm not going to take the
doorknob off so the kid can't get out
but I appreciate it and I will tell you
my wife suggested something along those
lines
because uh she's not built like me where
I'm I'm German Irish so I can just deny
anything that I'm feeling I can just
compartmentalize it until it [__]
it it
comes out and misdirected anger later on
in the day or [__] 20 years later but
my wife is really in tuned with her body
and it's just like I need eight hours
sleep so
um
it's messing with her more so than me
not to say that I'm a better parent
because there's other [__]
that messes with me does not mess with
her all right here we go all right for
all intents
I don't know how to say okay this is
Expressions if you're if you're new to
the podcast there's a bunch of
Expressions that people don't say
correctly and or they combine them with
other ones and oh [__] I heard one this
week and I forgot to write it down
oh
something about coming to blows
I forget I think I actually heard a
sportscaster say it all right for all
intents hey Bill I just realized that my
saying for all intensive purposes
you know what I said I said for all
intents and purposes for all intents and
purposes that's how I said it it's all
for all intensive purposes
wait
oh you say for all intensive purposes
makes me a dumbass
as the phrase is actually oh it is I am
getting for all intents and purposes
for all intensive purposes
well maybe people enunciate it they
didn't say it so fast because yours kind
of made sense to the point I thought
yours was right uh my learning this last
week really stings as I've been a
full-time writer for over 30 years
you got to forgive yourself man that's
not the first or the last at least you
corrected it
um how did I not know I was saying and
writing this phrase wrong
uh why did no one ever tell me for all
intents and purposes you are a dumbass
for saying that for saying that
incorrectly I am an idiot
oh what color I'm sorry I read that
wrong why did no one ever tell me for
all intents and purposes you are a
dumbass for saying that incorrectly I am
an idiot oh well you live you learn keep
doing what you do as it makes my life
more enjoyable best regards all right
one again good luck with your uh your
writing
um
all right what do we got left here what
do we have what do we have left here we
got one more everybody uh
uh help with expressions
hey Billy beat it beat tits Burr 46 year
old Mexican with the question number one
Uno look at me huh see a little tip of
the [__] hat there uh what does
hindsight's 2020 mean
all right question for you all right
hindsight's 2020
that means when you look back and all
the events have played out
uh you can see clearly what the right
choice was
number two dose
uh katorse as Bono would say uno katorse
uh and what the hell do you Americans
mean when you say well catch 22. catch
22 means damned if you do damned if you
don't there's no right choice
um
you're obviously not married if you
don't know what that means an
explanation from the mind of Burke could
definitely make my day okay so I
explained the first one
Catch 22 means you're [__] either way
do I go left or do I go right all right
on the left is a most poisonous snake in
the world on the right is uh [__]
that lethal injection that they give you
well I guess well no matter what you're
gonna die that's a bad example
well you know something I don't know
what where Catch-22 came from
catch 22.
origin
come on
[Music]
uh the 1960s title of Novel but not that
where did the expression Catch-22 come
from
comes from Joseph hyler's 1961 classic
novel Catch-22 a satirical depiction of
the American Military
bureaucracy in World War II
so he sort of coined the phrase
like why did he call the book catch-22
let's let's go a little deeper here
a catch-22 is a paradoxical situation
from which an individual cannot Escape
because of contradictory rules or
limitations the term was coined by
Joseph Heller who used it in his 1961
novel
uh catch 22.
and here's an example are you concerned
for your own safety in flying these
missions
no
then you continue flying the mission if
you say yes
this is rational so you cannot be
Exempted on the grounds of insanity so
you still have to fly the mission
oh yeah so if you say yes or no the
outcome's still going to be the same uh
catch 22s often result
from rules and regulations origin and
meeting here we go
all right Catch 22 which is just
describes absurd burratic constraints
yeah but why did he call it catch-22
all right I'm not going to be able then
I'm not going to answer that [__]
question
um
yeah so it basically someone is asking
you to do something crazy if you say no
you're like well that's the proper
response
um
so obviously you're sane enough to do
this so then they make you [__] do
and then I already forgot what happens
if you say yes
uh
uh are you concerned about your own
safety
well if you say no then well great
because you got the balls to do this so
no matter what you're gonna have to fly
the mission I guess that's what it is I
think I did better on the first one
um but anyway you should know better you
should know better than to ask me to
clear things up all right that is it I'm
gonna watch game two of the NBA finals
and I'm going to continue watching the
Stanley Cup Final and I'm going to start
watching baseball get caught up on my
Red Sox to see where there's at last I
checked we were two games over 500 and
in last place because the Devil Rays are
burning it up and the Baltimore Orioles
are in second place which is really
exciting to me because they always had
such great pitching staffs when I was
growing up and I'll be honest with you
I'm sick of Red Sox Yankees every
[__] year how about that all right
that's it go [__] yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday